her dog or her cat was named vagina the
judge wasn't allowed to put that in all
of these things he would but with her
they could put in anything Access
Hollywood jury of nine people who found
you liable of sexual abuse do you think
that that will deter women from voting
for you no I don't think so because I
think the whole thing
just so you understand ready
I never met this woman I never saw this
woman he never saw her I I don't believe
a word he's saying and then Trump
actually goes into a detailed story
about the circumstances I think I just
lost the light in my suit that was weird
goes into a detailed we'll get that
fixed up
he tells a story about what's being said
happened and it's one of the most
bizarre moments of the entire thing